i was watching this uh not not first 48
it was more than that where they dive
into like crime stories
i could i could not go to bed i saw it
finished because we were talking about
prison yeah dude
so a true story
this uh man and uh girl
go off to the military they're both
stationed in north korea they get
married but then they're stationed at
different stations
they come back from being stationed i
forget where it's at and they live in
like a trailer park whatever he gets he
he goes out he go he he goes to get food
for his wife and they have a kid
together he goes get food he gets gunned
down shot seven times shot in the back
of the head
shot the [ __ ] up dies
they have the police footage the body
cam of them walking up and the the wife
balling trying to get into the ambulance
balling like
how the [ __ ] how does that going nuts
and the dad's there and he's like my
son's a good boy this thing makes sense
blah blah and he's a big dude with
dreads big black guy
big dude and he's like this doesn't make
sense blah blah blah he's furious he's
like who the [ __ ] would do this so the
cops uh are looking the case like we
think it was a mistaken identity and
they thought he was a gang member
so they investigate that they find
nothing like man something has to be
going on here they talk to the
girlfriend
so they have the dad they ask that go
hey can you come down with the wife and
uh we need some question for you and he
goes yeah sure no problem she's like
yeah of course whatever it takes
the dad gets them they have this all on
camera the dad gets there and they go
we're gonna be a while won't you go home
and he's like what the [ __ ] that's like
because the wife was staying with the
family the whole time
saying that crying like and they were
you know trying to consult her and take
care of her so the dad goes what the
[ __ ] they go we're gonna be well won't
you go ahead and go home so they bring
in the best like uh
investigator in all the land they bring
him in he's the number one guy that does
the lie detector test she fails the lie
detector which happens and even admits
he goes sometimes soft but she lied
about a few things
so he keeps talking
she's there for seven hours she got
there at 11. she's there for seven hours
finally she's like all right
what happened is
i was dating another man it's not what
it seems i was dating a i started dating
another soldier because he would listen
to me started dating him
and uh he want to take care of the
problem and so when uh he was like
drove down from like memphis to like
texas wherever it's at drove down there
and the kid went out at night and he
would uh follow him in his car
but i guess there was he was going to do
it at night club but there's too many
witnesses so he waited so she was like
well the right time would come just stay
close
so
dude so when he went to get food she
texts her side piece he's going to get
food so he comes up shoots them right
shoots them they solve all this the
girl's behind all of it because he had a
insurance plan that where she would get
like five hundred thousand dollars what
a piece of [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] right this
is what's crazy that that this is all on
camera the dad goes into the prison
because he gets life the girl gets life
they're both [ __ ] yeah
the kid's [ __ ] right so the dad goes
into to talk to him because you want to
talk to the killer of his son he's
sitting down he's super mild-mannered
like big dude dreads he's sitting there
and uh the they're talking about it in
the sun and the killer's like i want you
to know man it was her plan like she she
wanted the the 500k
i was just caught up in it i apologize
she never got like this no dad's like no
i get it man i get it you're strapped
for cash i get why you would do this yep
he's like can you ever forgive me and
the dad he just doesn't answer but he's
cool i'm like why the flick's being so
cool
and then the then the killer goes
you look like you want to kill me right
now because i don't want to kill you he
was i don't know her name's like tiffany
he was i don't know if did tiffany ever
tell you what i what i used to do and
what i'm involved with and you see the
guy's like demeanor change he was no he
was
i got a lot of friends where you're at a
lot of friends and he was and you meet a
lot of friends
and he goes you can see his face turns
white he's a black dude's face he's like
mix he turns white and he goes what do
you what is that threadios saying you
meet a lot of friends in there
you meet a lot of you just kidding you
meet a lot of friends and he goes have a
good have a good night hangs up the
phone walks off then you interview the
dad uh at his house like days later and
they go uh he got lives are you happy
with that he goes yeah that's fine he
won't make it two years
and then just end it
i was like holy [ __ ] i could not get
enough of it yeah damn i got a lot of
friends in there my man because i don't
know if she told you the crowd i used to
run with but they're all in there and
you're making a lot of friends
and kept going what seminars you're
making a lot of friends
i was like holy [ __ ] you're [ __ ] up
yeah they're like well they gave him
life isn't that hap aren't you happy
with that he goes oh that's fine he
won't make it two years
didn't give a [ __ ] dude well here you
can holy cause you you and i know what
it's like his son also ran with that
same crowd oh yeah
you know exactly and then they and it's
like they're they dominate that wherever
whatever prison he was in there they're
just everywhere yeah you're not kidding
well you said a son ran with that crowd
too yeah he's like have a good have a
good night hangs up the phone
oh my god can you imagine that
tear
you're never gonna you and i have a son
so you don't even know how much you love
that kid like it's it's beyonce oh my
god he's [ __ ] kidding me you just you
don't care anymore about anything i
don't want peace no you you you gotta do
something like that i don't want but
this dad was so mild manner in control
i'm like how's he not going crazy the
murder's literally two inches away from
through this because he oh he's just
listening he's like
i want you in the ground yeah yeah
that's you're on this on the problem you
want him in the ground there's no other
alternative yeah in the ground but dude
the way this that that the wife was like
when the kid was shot like on the body
cam i'm like like freaking out crying
and he was like she's a good actor man
she's like she's a good actor she's a
pizza she had no remote morse either
like they were like do you want to say
anything to them she's like
a sociopath yeah that's what he said he
was like it's crazy because she she's
like my daughter she stayed with us
full-time like she would give us how
could she do that too yeah
living with people dude some people and
they had no child together
oh my god
what a [ __ ] monster piece of [ __ ]